what we're going to do in this video is
talk a little bit more about federal
powers versus estate powers and as we've
mentioned in other videos this is a very
relevant topic because even today you'll
have Supreme Court decisions being
decided based on citing different parts
of the Constitution or various
amendments that seem to give one power
another more to the federal government
or to the state government and another
important appreciation is the balance of
power or the shifts of power between
federal and state it has historically
changed over time so it isn't this fixed
thing so in a previous video we talked
about the enumerated powers that the
Constitution gives the federal
government in particular we have talked
about the Commerce Clause that allows
the federal government to regulate
commerce among the several states which
has turned out to be a much farther
reaching power than maybe the drafters
of the Constitution intended and then
the thing that really gives power to
even the enumerated powers is the
Necessary and Proper Clause to make all
laws which shall be necessary and proper
for carrying into execution the
foregoing powers and so this is what we
talked about this Necessary and Proper
Clause creates a lot of implied powers
so you can imagine this isn't the
Necessary and Proper Clause is not
something that made the anti-federalists
very happy they were worried about kind
of power grabs by the federal government
and so shortly after you have the
ratification of the Constitution you
have the ratification of the Bill of
Rights which are the first ten
amendments and the ninth and tenth
amendment in particular are anti
federalists attempt to limit the federal
government's power
so the ninth amendment says the
enumeration in the constitution of
certain rights shall not be construed to
deny or disparage others retained by the
people and even more important the Tenth
Amendment and this is really speaking to
federal versus state powers the powers
not delegated to the United States by
the Constitution so not delegated to the
federal government nor prohibited by it
the federal government too
the states are reserved to the States
respectively or to the people and so you
could view this as reserved powers for
the states it's an anti federalists
attempt to say hey you know the federal
government can't just do whatever it
wants it's trying to put a little bit of
a check on the Necessary and Proper
Clause so if you fast-forward to the
period right after the Civil War
you have the Thirteenth Amendment which
bans slavery and then you have the 14th
amendment which is trying to bring
slaves into society allow them to be
citizens not just them but their
descendants and this is in direct
contradiction of the 1857 Dred Scott
decision that we'll talk about in other
videos where the US Supreme Court ruled
that slaves and their descendants are
not considered American citizens and so
they don't have a right to petition the
government but the 14th Amendment says
all persons born or naturalized in the
United States and subject to the
jurisdiction thereof are citizens of the
United States and of the State wherein
they reside no State shall make or
enforce any law and so this is actually
putting constrains on states and so as
we'll see even though this is in the
context of the post-civil war era
because it's putting constraints on
States this is one of the amendments
that's often cited that puts more power
in the hands of the federal government
no State shall make or enforce any law
which shall abridge the privileges or
immunities of citizens of the United
States nor shall any state deprive any
person of life liberty or property
without due process of law nor deny to
any person within its jurisdiction the
equal protection of the laws and so
since the time that the 14th amendment
was adopted this notion of equal
protection under the law that no state
can inform make or enforce laws which
shall abridge the privileges or
immunities of citizens and the 14th
amendment has been very relevant in a
whole series of cases in modern time a
lot of cases around discrimination if
there's a right that is given in one
state do the other states have to adopt
it you
look around right now there's
significant social debates about things
like same-sex marriage or things like
abortion and those cases often center
around the 14th amendment